it's Friday April 25th and you're
watching gamespot news I'm your host
Chris waters here to distill an entire
week's worth of complex and nuanced
stories into an easily digestible top 5
list and because I've just made a food
metaphor I'm legally required to tell
you that this broadcast contains no
nutritional value and is gluten free
hooray news in a week chock-full of game
companies saying they get glowing things
about the games they're making Bungie
has done the best job of teasing us
mercilessly in their latest weekly
update Bungie revealed that they had a
bunch of writers visit their offices
recently and that quote the floodgates
are about to burst wide open Bungie
wrote we talked a big game last year now
it's time to deliver we owe that to
ourselves and to our legacy but most of
all we owe it to you now I try to avoid
feeling entitled as a gamer I don't
think companies oh us anything until
we've given them money but if I don't
see some serious destiny footage by the
end of e3 i am going to strongly
consider writing a very firm and
indignant tweet Generalissimo facebook
himself Mark Zuckerberg scouted out the
Sony competition before buying oculus VR
Zuckerberg apparently asked for a tech
demo a while back and got a chance to
try out Sony's project Morpheus VR
headset for himself no word on how he
felt about the hardware he used but
there are about two billion hints that
he thinks there's a big future in
virtual reality Facebook's bid to
acquire oculus VR made waves a few weeks
ago and according to a report by Reuters
the purchase was just approved by the
federal trade commission do you think
that purchase bodes well for the future
of the oculus rift let us know with a
like or a dislike below I'm just kidding
like is the only option wait did we get
bought by Facebook speaking of buying if
you're looking to buy an xbox one you
might be able to score one for around
four hundred bucks at Best Buy starting
this weekend from Sunday to 27 through
Saturday the third if you trade in a
working xbox 360 or ps3 at best buy
you'll receive at least a fifty dollar
gift card as well as a fifty-dollar
coupons
use towards the purchase of an xbox one
that's at least a hundo towards your new
X bone possibly more depending on which
model console you trade in and though
that four hundred fifty dollar titanfall
bundle is no longer available it's still
a good opportunity if you've been
waiting to make the leap and don't mind
saying goodbye to the console generation
that has seen you through close to a
decade of fond gaming memories you're
gonna have to upgrade sometime if you
want to get in on project cars a
next-gen racing game that released a
shiny new trailer this week the latest
in car porn comes from slightly mad
studios developers of need for speed
shift and world of speed and they claim
it will be quote the most authentic
beautiful and technically advanced
racing game on the planet I mean on this
planet sure but how does it stack up
against the intense speed and flashy
concept cars of red faction guerrillas
Martian street racing that is the true
test and finally some crazy idiot called
in a SWAT team on a 17 year old kid
after losing a call of duty match idiot
the unhinged chucklehead apparently
called the police and impersonated his
target claiming he had just killed his
own mother and might shoot more people
over 60 officers of the Long Island
police department followed up on the
utter knit wits false threat and found
that everything in the target house was
just fine police are currently
investigating where the threat
originated from so they can find the
abject imbecile who is responsible I
just cannot believe how some utter
morons do the stupidest crap that you
could ever imagine and then they don't
think that they're gonna get punished
for it god damn them they are terrible
that's the top five news stories for
this week and that's almost a wrap for
our show because I want to give you guys
a little bonus for being a great
audience the petition to bring GTA 5 to
pc has surpassed 700 thousand signatures
i don't know why i made a five with my
hands just then i'm chris waters thanks
for watching have a great weekend
you